hello my name is John pesckow I work for
Wolfram research on the cloud project
and I will talk about the cloud notebook
interface the progress we've made in the
last year and give some examples of what
you can do with it hello my name is John
Bosco I work on the Wolfram cloud
project when reading the development of
the cloud notebook interface mostly
that's what I want to talk about today i
will give a brief introduction into
cloud notebooks try to explain some of
the difficulties of trying to render
notebooks in web browsers and show some
of the technology we use in the
background and then highlight some of
the things that we've achieved over the
past year and and show some things you
can do now that you probably couldn't do
a year ago with cloud notebooks probably
all of you know the desktop interface of
Mathematica where you edit your
documents you enter expressions you do
your computations in a really nice
notebook interface and you probably also
share notebook files with with other
people and all of this nice experience
that's what we want to bring to the web
that that's our mission so the idea is
that you can use notebooks as you know
them from Mathematica in web in a web
browser without installing a local into
installation of Mathematica without
installing a plug-in just go to your to
a URL you know open the website and it's
a it's a fully featured notebook
interface where you can interact with
your content and to make this a bit more
exciting i'm actually using a cloud
notebook right now so what you see here
is not a desktop mathematica but it's
actually a web browser running a local
installation of the clouds and and so
this is what I would call a cloud
notebook in slideshow mode as you know
it from from desktop Mathematica um
so let me start with a few basic things
it should increase this little um so as
that this is a cloud notebook running in
a web browser but as usual i can i can
type some text here i can i can have
section cells edit that I can do
evaluations of course so if i create a
new input cell on plus 2 and press shift
enter i get a get a result as usual we
also have this nice predictive interface
here so i can click here and go on we
also have some some code assist features
so as you type you can see some some
auto completions here i can i can select
the function select a template for a
function call and and things like that
um we also have pretty nice support for
graphics in cloud notebooks so if i
evaluate this plot i get i get this
thing of course i can i can resize
graphics so by dragging this around let
it go bigger graphic now but it's also
pretty cool is i think 3d graphics again
this is all purely running in a web
browser but still i'm able to have a 3d
plot like this and no use my mouse and
rotate this what we've added rather
recently that i can also select this and
and resize this as usual so i think that
that's pretty cool um we also are
continuously improving support for
typesetting so if you have a rather
complex result like this it still looks
pretty nice in the web browser there are
some things we have to improve further
parentheses are probably a little too
big but otherwise it's it's pretty
nicely typeset math again all
all in a web browser what also pretty
cool is support for dynamics in
notebooks and I think we've made some
good progress there so in its most basic
form what we support is dynamic of some
variable and as usual that just this
place as as the variable itself until it
gets a value as soon as I change the
value of bar let's say to you can see
that the output up there immediately
updated as soon as I change this
variable here I can also construct all
user interfaces on top of this so if I
have a button with a certain caption it
can increment it variable and now when I
click it you see that the value up there
changes dynamically we've also just
rather recently added support for
dynamic option values so you can have
something like this where you have a
piece of text where the font color comes
dynamically from a certain variable now
as soon as I assign something let's say
I want this to be read the text changes
its color maybe even cooler is I've got
if I connected to a color setter with a
dynamic setting then you can see it it's
immediately read but I can click this
select a different color press ok and
again text up there changes so that's
sort of a way to build complex user
interfaces in in Mathematica in regular
Wolfram language which still work in a
web browser sort of our way of doing of
doing two-way data binding in web
applications now if you if you have
tried web programming before you can
already appreciate probably this is not
an easy thing to do but but for
everybody else just want to quickly
demonstrate what's what's hard about
this problem and they're basically 22
of challenges the one is that we have to
make sure that that type setting in
general works correctly that's what you
really expect when you work in a cloud
notebook or in a notebook in general of
course you want your math or any output
to look nicely of course and and some of
the challenges there are custom line
breaking that Mathematica does in a
pretty nice way but also things like
baseline alignment and things like that
so you have to make sure that that works
properly but then in addition there are
all sorts of dynamic interactive
elements that you can easily construct
interval from language that we have to
support in in cloud notebooks so if you
take something like this like a grid
with a pretty large number and it also
has a second column with another number
what you would expect and what do you
actually get in a cloud notebook is that
it line wraps nicely you know it you
don't get horizontal scrolling the
number line reps here you get you get
sort of three digit groups to make the
number more readable and this is aligned
here and so on it it looks pretty nice
and that's you have all right to expect
it of course but if you think about
plain HTML I mean it's easy to generate
that you can have a table in HTML with
some with some cells and mathematica
will actually generate this for you if
you say export string to HTML fragment
but when you then look at this and I'll
just use a simple cloud object with with
this HTML code to demonstrate this so if
you go there now what the browser does
is is not looking very nice I mean this
is just a table with this single very
long line and then this is not aligned
very nicely I mean maybe we could work
around this in this particular case but
that's just to illustrate that the
browser by itself would not do at all
but what we want here and when it gets
more sophisticated or I mean not even to
sophistic but you have something like
like a fraction here all that's really
possible
in the end is to generate an image so in
this case if you ask for the HTML
fragment it will actually produce an
inline HTML image um but yeah that's
that's not really what we want and the
reason is that the output should still
stay interactive we still want buttons
to work tooltips to work so using plain
images is not really an option for us
and so so yeah that that basically means
that we have to take care of all the
typesetting of all the layout of output
and also input in in notebooks ourselves
we can't rely on the browser we have to
implement basically a layout engine in
JavaScript from a very low level on and
what this means in turn is that we have
to implement the box language of
Mathematica some some of you might be
familiar with this but but just to
illustrate is whenever you have some
output in in Mathematica like this this
simple formula here what's going on in
the background is actually a symbolic
representation of this visual thing and
you can see this by applying two boxes
so what Mathematica does in the
background is it turns this into a row
box of a fraction box and then there's a
superscript box you can also look at the
tree form of this sort of a nested
structure that represents this this
visual output up there and it suppose a
very general theme in Mathematica that
everything can be represented as an
expression which is really nice and that
also applies to to visual output so it
ended there's over 100 different boxes
overall there's some related to graphics
both 2d and 3d then there's some boxes
related to traditional mathematical
typesetting and then there's many boxes
for dynamic controls like buttons and so
on and so
one of the major challenges and tasks
that we have to do is implement these
boxes basically in JavaScript so that
they work in a web browser and the way
we've we've addressed is sort of evolved
over time so in the beginning of the
project that I mean that the very lowest
bass line was basically to produce
image-based output but that's how things
started things looked fairly okay but
they were not interactive at all and for
the editor i guess the baseline is a
very simple plain text editor basically
just using a text area as the browser
would provide anybody but then over time
I mean one thing that's we realized that
one thing it's very important is of
course manipulates so we added a custom
JavaScript based implementation for
manipulate which meant that when you
evaluate and manipulate we would
intercept that at a very high level and
replace whatever it would do otherwise
with some very custom JavaScript widget
that support things like simple sliders
and image-based output within but it
there was no chance this would evolve
into a full fully featured manipulate as
you know it from from desktop
mathematica with all the options
regarding layout and controlled
positioning and these things we did the
same for 3d graphics and 2d graphics
which meant that if you had graphics at
the top level of a cell it would be sort
of interactive but as soon as you nested
things they they didn't work as nicely
anymore um for the editor we gradually I
added some nice syntax highlighting some
some auto completions and so on and
that's basically where we were at last
year I think and what happened in the
within the the past year is that we
switched to a very
of fundamental you know low level
implementation of most of what most of
the boxes in JavaScript so that's that's
what I was mentioning earlier that we
really have to take care of all this
typesetting now in JavaScript and we are
also making use of that same technology
in the editor so when you when you have
a large number and you know you want to
edit it it still stays in that nice mode
where you have nice line wrapping here
and as you edit it it it doesn't
overflow the notebook then that's a
consequence of using the same kind of
rendering pipeline for both output and
input so that's that's where we are
right now basically um what's ahead of
us is basically extending support for
more boxes I think we have a very solid
framework now and it's just a matter of
implementing a few more boxes and all
their options and eventually whatever we
want to get at is a an actual box based
editor so so right now it's still kind
of one-dimensional texts that you can
edit but eventually we'll definitely
want to get it something more
two-dimensional that you can edit grids
superscripts and all sorts of
mathematical constructs of course so
that's that's kind of the outline of the
evolution of this interface what this
means now is that when you evaluate
something or you interact with the
browser page that JavaScript client it
basically makes requests to the cloud
where there's a Java server that
basically just passes on expressions to
a Wolfram engine running also in the
cloud or the kernel as you might call it
which at least if it produces output
will respond with a box expression as
we've seen it so for instance row box of
a fraction box of something that goes
back to the Java layer which then make
sure that this is saved into the
notebook and so on but then it basically
just passes
on expressions to the JavaScript client
we encoded in JSON but it's still very
much just a raw box expression and then
the JavaScript client takes care of
taking this expression and rendering it
on on-screen get sort of the loop how
this works just a few words about what's
going on in the background in the
JavaScript layer so we use something
that's very natural user in such a case
is Model View and sometimes controller
model our architecture for the model we
basically have this tree from the note
book down to individual cells and boxes
where use JavaScript libraries like like
backbone and underscore to deal with
that so something interesting is how we
deal with with options like we saw font
color and font size all these things
there are options that have to be passed
down through this tree to individual
boxes we're at each layer some things
might change but probably not too many
of them will change and there it
actually makes sense to use immutable
persistent data structures which work
pretty nicely in JavaScript as well so
yeah that's about the model and when it
comes to rendering things on screen
that's what if you comes in and they're
the task is basically to render the
model into a collection of Dom nodes
which is the representation of content
that the browser understands and in each
step we have to keep track of dimension
information which is the width the
height and the baseline of everything so
that we can lay out things on screen
what we do is actually we using a
library called react in JavaScript which
abstracts this a little bit so whenever
or at least very rarely interacting with
the browser directly modifying the dorm
but instead we build up a virtual
representation of the content as you see
it in the browser
and then this library makes sure that
the browser is updated in the most
efficient way because usually the dome
is really the bottleneck in in browser
interactions goods yeah I think you very
nice library just just in case you're
interested um okay so that's about some
of the things we do in terms of the
JavaScript client now some of the just
want to show some of the things that
that work that have never worked before
in in cloud notebooks and and one very
important use case is of course
manipulates so if you have a rather
complex manipulate like this here it
will work it will work now and you can
see it has a rather be at least rather
custom control layout on the left-hand
side you have some nested objects in
this area and as you drag a slider you
can see that both sides update what's
also cool is that these graphics are
interactive now so it can resize this as
usual I can also go here and resize this
so so these are the sorts of things that
are possible now because of the
arbitrary nesting of of boxes basically
and the full understanding of boxes in
in JavaScript it also works for 3d
graphics of course so if you have a
manipulate with a 3d plot you can both
drag the slider slider and also drag
this 3d graphics here of course so
that's just a couple of examples about
manipulate we also in in general
increased support for for dynamic
dynamic module and event handler for
instance i want you i want to give a
quick example of what's possible now so
the idea is to to make graphics zoomable
i think that's a pretty nice feature on
its own but what's even nicer is that
you can implement this now in top-level
Wolfram language code
without touching the JavaScript client
of course um and what this does is I
have a plot just just the random
graphics and a raptis in this zoomable
function I get applauded as usual but
what I can do now is I can click and
drag up a rectangle I'm going to let go
it zooms into this area I mean I could I
could make this more sophisticated maybe
add a button to go back reset the plot
range and things like that and as I said
the nice thing is that this is all coded
in top level code so what it basically
does is you have a dynamic module that
keeps track of the corners of the
rectangle that you draw out that you
draw and then that is used inside the
dynamic construct inside the graphics
also we make use of dynamic option
values so that the plot range is
basically a dynamic value and when you
click and drag the mouse it's using an
event handler to modify these these
variables but what's going on in the
background this is pretty cool actually
because the only way to make this work
reasonably well without lagging too much
is by using a client-side evaluator so
there are some some expressions like you
know that this first variable is
assigned the mouse position and that
there could be a more complex expression
here of course but at least for for some
sorts of expressions where were able to
not go back to the colonel to evaluate
them but we stay on the client side in
JavaScript and implemented evaluated
right away which means that you can
basically construct pretty dynamic
interactive user interfaces in top level
code that still run purely in in
JavaScript in the web browser of course
this is still in a rather early stage so
not everything
works in terms of event handler for
instance but but we definitely have a
have a great part forward there um
alright so let's say you have some some
some nice content that you want to share
with others what what you do now how to
deploy it to the cloud it's actually
pretty easy so if you have something
like this manipulate all you have to
call its cloud deploy of this thing it
will give you a cloud object again this
is this is running on my my local
version of the cloud but otherwise we'll
just get a booth from cloud URL you go
there and then you have the interactive
manipulate in a sort of minimal notebook
interface cloudy blow actually tries to
be a bit clever so if you have something
like rather static expression it will
not produce an interactive notebook but
it will actually just rasterize the
output and produce something that looks
like a notebook I think that makes sense
in many cases where you just care about
the visual representation if you do want
to make the distinction you might want
to use cloud export that's very similar
to what we did above just cloud export
in the content and then say that you
want a cloud CDF and that will make sure
that it always becomes an interactive
notebook so if i visit this object i get
you know a notebook right something else
to keep in mind when when dealing with
cloud objects and deploying things to
the cloud are permissions so what you've
seen here these cloud objects they're
actually private by default and the
reason I can still see them is because
i'm logged in obviously but i mean first
of all you couldn't even go to my local
host anyway but if you could you could
still not see them because they're just
all private to me if you want to make
things public you have to use
permissions and that's an option to
things like cloud deploy cloud export
and similar functions and then the handy
shortcut is permissions goes to public
which in the context of notebooks means
that its interactive for any user so we
can see at the full form of these
permissions options it says now that
that everybody even unauthenticated
users have read and interact permissions
that that's something to keep in mind
there's a pretty detailed documentation
about permissions which you might want
to read um no um you might wonder with
all that fancy JavaScript going on isn't
that becoming slow at some point this
doesn't it take a long time to you know
just download all the JavaScript to the
client render things in a JavaScript
evaluation until you see anything on
screen and that's that's actually true
and that we were concerned about that as
well so now way we address that is that
we cache a raw version of the notebook
and HTML based based version of the
notebook when you edit and enclose the
notebook so no as you close the notebook
we store a pure HTML based
representation of at least the upper
part the part that's usually visible of
a notebook on the server side and then
when you next open the notebook could be
you or anybody else that's the thing
that we sent down to the client
initially so whatever the browser
immediately sees is this raw HTML
version that it can immediately render
and it's very fast with that while in
the background we download all the
necessary JavaScript code all the
necessary resources and so on so I just
want to click want to give a quick demo
of that if we plow deploy this
manipulate I i put a little delay in
there i know that the just evaluate
something but but you also pause for
three seconds for this to be
for this effect to be more visible so
now when we first go to this object we
see it takes a little while to to
generate this manipulate and usually
that that might even be a little longer
because I'm running my local machine now
so there's not much of a network
overhead but you might imagine that on
the internet there's more more overhead
in you know downloading all the
JavaScript and additional resources but
but here for for the demos purpose I I
just added this artificial delayed so
you saw this little delay and they've
diverse this little dot animation
spinning but now let's close this one
and open it again and now this just
comes in immediately as you might have
seen and also notice that there was no
real transition that's what we worked on
pretty hard to make sure that you don't
really notice the transition from the
cached version that's just raw HTML to
the life JavaScript based rendering of
the notebook and content so now I can
still wait oh it takes a while because
of this artificial three-second pause
but but of course this is this is
interactive as usual um right that's the
idea with or HTML caching we've also
made some some mobile specific
improvements that it's also very
relevant interesting area of course you
want to be able to not only few
notebooks in in traditional web browsers
on desktop computers but you also want
to deliver them to mobile devices and so
what we did is we worked worked on an
mobile application at least for iOS four
now an app for Android is coming up as
well where we basically wrapped the
cloud notebooks technology in a nice app
that allows you to browse through your
cloud files and
phew shared files and so on and then it
then it then you can open notebooks and
other cloud objects and you get an
optimized experience in terms of
interacting within out with the notebook
so for instance we provide a custom
keyboard that makes sense for willful
language and and selections of cells and
you know moving a selection around that
work slightly differently on on mobile
devices that's the story there Oh
another thing I want to briefly mention
is embedding notebooks I think that's
that's quite relevant so you might have
some you know content some some
manipulate that works really nicely in
in its notebook form but then you might
still have your general website your
company website and you probably don't
want to switch everything over to to a
notebook interface I mean in an ideal
world maybe everything would be a
notebook but it's totally understandable
that there is still HTML out there
there's lots of HTML so we want we want
these we don't want to create an island
that and not be able to interact with
with other things so what you can
absolutely do is of course embed
notebooks in an iframe um so you know
and then actually there's a function
called embed code that should give you
that little piece of HTML you need to
embed a notebook in an HTML page but
then I think what's also really
interesting is to be able to interact
with that notebook from the outside
world basically so you might want to be
able to you know create cells from
JavaScript using some JavaScript code
and create cells in the notebook you
embedded or do all sorts of things and
and we're just creating an API that
allows you to interact with notebooks
from other JavaScript code gonna give a
quick demo of that I basically created a
small
HTML page i actually created this in the
cloud so that's the the cloud interfaces
you would usually see it and you can not
only create notebooks here but as you
might know you can also create HTML
pages for instance and so this is the
HTML editor where you can see an iframe
here that's just referencing another
notebook I've created before and then
there is some JavaScript code let me
first show you what it does so it looks
like this Oh should have actually
deleted this all right don't have to
believe this um the idea is that you
have this regular HTML page and then
then this embedded notebook you can see
it's you know it's it's still a regular
notebook where can type in of course but
now I can also use these buttons here to
interact with the notebook so this one
is asking me for an expression to insert
and then it will create a corresponding
input cell and immediately evaluate it I
have already created this dynamic plot
here there's a little bug with the plot
labels me you can ignore that um but so
so you can you could so great cells here
now can also evaluate arbitrary
expressions and basically send them into
the notebook which will forward them to
the colonel if necessary so if i now
enter a new value in this JavaScript
interface it will go to the notebook and
update and update this plot immediately
and the way this is done in the code is
quite straightforward basically we have
this notebook interface class in in
JavaScript that has functions like
insert cell that cursor evaluate a cell
evaluate expression and so on and one
particularly nice thing that we can do
with this is for instance animate things
so by pressing this button javascript
will go ahead
just use an interval and update the
variable T continuously and you can see
that the notebook updates accordingly um
so in the code sorry it's it's as simple
as as this here basically um yeah so
stop this of course you should also be
able to do all of these things in in the
Wolfram language and we're definitely
working on on the tail animator box and
things like that but but it might still
be nice to be able to control things
from from JavaScript if you want to um
there is a sa we just started working on
this there is quite a few API methods
already armed but it's it's not
completely stable and documented yet but
but I definitely like to know if you
have some use case for this movie that
can inform how we design it and document
this API and that's pretty much what i
wanted to say about not notebooks just
to give a quick summary I've tried to
explain some of the reasons by notebook
rendering in browser browsers is hard
showing you what what progress we've
made what you can do now um some of the
things we're very actively working on is
still extending support for boxes in in
the web browser while also improving
performance of notebook rendering and
also the editor in particular we also
keep adding input assist features like
more intelligent auto completions and
then something really important I think
is extending documentation of things
that work and that don't work in the
cloud so far we haven't done that too
much because things have been changing
quite a bit and it didn't make sense to
say something didn't work when a month
later it would work anyway but I think
now things are converging more and
and we'll definitely be better with
documenting these things then more
future directions for cloud notebooks
are certainly the two dimensional box
based editor of already mentioned
earlier and something we also really
want to get at is life collaboration on
cloud notebooks meaning that two or more
users can work on the same notebook at
the same time and seeing each other's
changes that would really be nice to be
really nice I think um alright that's so
all I wanted to say thank you very much
very much for your attention